Speaker 1: Okay. So as yesterday's explosive
testimony from Cassidy Hutchinson was taking place
on Washington, D.C., on Capitol Hill, remember,
under oath in front of the January six committee,
Donald Trump had a complete
and total childish meltdown,
untruth, social. Which only further sort of
suggests that the allegations about his completely
losing his temper and throwing ketchup
at the wall are accurate. She was under
oath. Trump was untruth.
Speaker 4: Social censure.
Speaker 1: Yes, exactly. Take a look at this
extraordinarily childish meltdown from Donald
Trump on his platform as the testimony was
going on. Quote, I hardly know who this person,
Cassidy Hutchinson, is, other than I heard very
negative things about her, a total phony and
leaker. And when she requested to go with certain
others of the team to Florida, after my having
served a full term in office, I personally turned
her request down. Why did she want to go with us
if she felt we were so terrible? I understand
she was very upset and angry that I didn't want
her to go or to be a member of the team. She is
bad news. Well, first of all, if she's leaking,
she's leaking accurate information. You
don't leak. You don't fabricate leaks.
It's either a leak or a lie. Secondly, she is
under huge legal pressure. It's not that she
all of a sudden disagrees with MAGA. In fact,
this is why I don't see Cassidy Hutchinson as
a hero. She's acting out of self-preservation.
She's not like some of these other big names.
She is under serious legal pressure here. And
so she showed up and she told the truth as she
recalls it. Trump, continuing, never complained
about the crowd. This is the size of the crowd.
CASSIDY Hutchinson testified Trump wasn't happy
with the size of the crowd. On January 6th,
Trump wrote Never complain about this, about the
crowd. It was massive. I didn't want or request
that we make room for people with guns to watch my
speech. Who would ever want that? Not me. Besides,
there were no guns found or brought into the
Capitol building. So where were all of these guns?
But sadly, a gun was used on Ashley Babbitt with
no price to pay against the person who used it.
Trump going on her fake story that I tried
to grab the steering wheel of the White House
limousine in order to steer it to the Capitol
building is sick and fraudulent. Very much like
the UN Select Committee itself wouldn't even have
been possible to do such a ridiculous thing. Her
story of me throwing throwing food is also false.
And why would she have to clean it up? I hardly
knew who she was. Well, when you're Trump, lots of
people you hardly know are cleaning up after you,
sir. Then Trump can Trump losing it over this
testimony. She changed lawyers a couple of days
ago, and with it, her story totally changed.
Shocker going on. Cheney conveniently left out
the snippet in my speech to go peacefully
and patriotically. Isn't she disgraceful?
Trump going on. There is no cross-examination of
this so-called witness. This is a kangaroo court.
Well, remember, Republicans opted out of
participating other than Adam Kinzinger and
Liz Cheney. Her body language is that of a total
bull artist. Fantasyland Trump Continuing. Will
anybody ever be allowed to say the election
was rigged and stolen? Will the UN select ever
discussed that our country is going to hell
because of a fraudulent election? How about
analyzing the election results? Trump continuing.
I never said Mike Pence deserves it to be hung.
Another made up statement by a third rate
social climber. Trump continuing a total phony.
Trump continuing reacting to a note placed
up on the screen that was written by Cassidy
Hutchinson in bad handwriting, that of a
wacko. Trump continuing. Why didn't they
use the 10,000 troops I offered up on January
3rd? There would have been no January 6th.
Actually, there has been no evidence found that
Trump had 10,000 troops ready to go. No evidence
whatsoever. Trump continuing the woman who was
a big Trump fan long after January 6th. If her
fake stories were true, why would she want to be
was let go and not wanted in Florida? So she made
up phony and completely outrageous stories, the
crazy of which the craziest of which has already
been proven to be a complete lie. That's not true.
Nothing has been proven to be a lie. The Secret
Service said, according to the media, it wasn't
true. Wow. She has now lost all credibility,
just like the partizan witch hunt perpetuated by
the UN Select Committee of Political Hacks MAGA.
Well, put them under oath, sir. Put them
under oath. TRUMP Then this morning, waking up
with more of it, saying The New York Times and
Washington Post failed to even mention that
today's UN Select Witness lost all credibility
when she got caught in a ridiculous lie. Our
country has lost all confidence in the media and
our elections. Sad. Nothing has been proven false.
Donald Trump completely and totally losing it in
a meltdown of historic proportions. If anything,
Trump melting down this badly for nearly 24
hours, suggests the claims made in the committee
hearing by Cassidy Hodgkinson are at least quite
plausibly true and should be investigated. And
if there are people who want to swear an oath
and come in and say I have a different view,
then they should be invited to do it. But
Donald Trump losing it. Untruth. Senator
Troeth Essential truth social while Cassidy
Hutchinson is under oath. To me, I know where
I'm going to lean in believing I trust the person
whose under oath. Unless we get some contradictory
testimony under oath. So that's Trump's
reaction. Let's now go to Fox News's reaction.